ça a commencé par une conversation
banale mon téléphone est posé devant moi
je parle d'une bouteille de whisky à un
collègue
quelques minutes plus tard cette
bouteille n'est pas une autre se
retrouve dans mon fils facebook
alors on s'est demandés comme beaucoup
est ce que nos téléphones enregistrent
de l'audio pour nous vendre de la
publicité
crypto québec connaît à peu près toutes
les traces qu'on laisse sur internet
la manière dont la plateforme est fait
les cc un code source qui ferme et donc
on peut pas des personnes qui sont
externes à facebook ne peuvent pas
regarder le fonctionnement ne peuvent
pas regarder comment les données sont
traitées
donc est-ce que de l'audio est utilisé
il ya pas moyen de le savoir
hors de tout doute en ce moment les
micros ne sait ce qu'est facebook dit et
puis ce qui est observable
et voici donc ce que monsieur facebook a
dit devant le congrès américain l'année
dernière aujourd'hui le micro les gens
se focalisent beaucoup sur micro et
c'est sûr que ça peut certaines applis
vont l'utiliser mais je pense que ça
peut venir de plein d'autres sources ce
spécialiste est formel oui on est traqué
sur internet et de différentes manières
il ya plein de façons de tracer un
individu le micro c'est l'audio c'est
une partie mais ça peut être le
comportement de navigation la
géolocalisation le fait de croiser l
usage qui est fait du téléphone avec les
recherches que vous faites sur votre
ordinateur
car les géants du web récolte une somme
d'informations colossale sur nous la
galaxie de google par exemple est
représenté sur ce tableau une épingle
égale une branche de google
et au milieu de tout ses épingles li a
marqué wynn ho hau wah nous servir ou
vous êtes aussi ce que tout ce que vous
faites ce que vous voulez ce désir et
c'est ça oui absolument à gogo dance
niant avoir énormément d'informations
sur les différentes activités des
personnes et c'est la même affaire pour
facebook de manière relativement
conservatrice mon plaisir que facebook
100 points de données différents sur les
utilisateurs
un point de donner ça peut être le nom
le code postal le numéro de téléphone
célibataire ou en couple ou le sport
préféré par exemple et nos données qu'on
peut penser protéger circulent parfois
en toute liberté
c'est ce qu'a mis en avant une étude de
la northeastern university au
massachussetts ils ont étudié 17000
application pendant plusieurs mois pour
voir quelles informations elle
partageait une des choses qu'ils ont mis
en avant qui était très peu connu avant
c'est le fait aussi qu'on puisse prendre
des captures d'écran lorsque vous tapez
ou de ce que vous regardez ce qui est
aussi une information extrêmement
personnel
ce qui nous amène à un deuxième cas
troublants un collègue reçoit par texto
la photo de son père sur une planche
quatre heures plus tard la planche en
question apparaît dans une publicité
facebook ça ne choquerait pas que
justement par la capture d'écran on
n'est plus associé que cette personne
n'a été assez intéressé par le
paddleboard qu'on le mette dans son
profil et donc quand ils aillent sur
facebook ils reçoivent la publicité
d'après cette information bon par contre
l'histoire de la bouteille de whisky ça
serait plutôt une drôle de coïncidence
parce qu'internet sait déjà que ça
m'intéresse exemple si je vais sur ce
site un message m'accueille en disant
attention on collecte des données avec
un objectif en particulier nous vous
proposons la publicité personnalisée
ceku qui se souviennent des sites que
vous avez pu visiter avant et vous
propose une publicité adaptée faut
s'imaginer avec nos d'année comme la
bourse mansart en temps réel il ya des
personnes qui vont collecter celles qui
vont les vendre au plus offrant
donc non votre téléphone ne vous écoute
probablement pas mais s'il enregistre
avec le gps ou le wifi que vous êtes
dans un magasin de chaussures
ne vous étonnez pas quelques heures plus
tard de recevoir de la publicité pour
des bottes d'hiver par exemple
toute une coïncidence quand même mathieu
cette histoire de bouteille de whisky le
scotch parce que si nous écoute pas
c'est de la magie
une coïncidence un croisement de données
entre les recherches que j'avais fait
précédemment
et puis effectivement coïncidence
troublante la question qu'on se pose
patrice comment se prémunir comment
essayer de d'éviter que toutes ces
données personnelles soient disséminés
dans la nature
premier réflexe arrêtez votre gps le
plus souvent possible arrêter le wifi
quand vous n'êtes pas chez vous quand
vous n'êtes pas au travail et puis quand
vous naviguez sur internet on le voyait
dans sur l'ordinateur de notre experte
de crypto québec
vous pouvez utiliser un bloqueur de
cookies les cookies sont donc ces petits
fichiers témoin qui glane de
l'information sur vous le plus populaire
c'est pour les possibles à jo ça
s'ajoute à votre navigateur vous voyez
là par exemple sur cnn jeter sur sienne
est ce que vous voyez sur surligner
est-ce qu amazon a besoin de savoir ce
que je consulte sur cnn peut-être pas
mais les cookies les fichiers témoins
sont importants si vous voulez connaître
la météo vous voulez qu'ils sachent dans
quelle ville vous êtes si vous voulez en
celsius ou en forme n'être que vous êtes
en français sauf que c'est à
l'utilisateur de faire le tri au milieu
de tous ces fichiers témoins pour
certains les activer l'autre les
désactiver donc le fardeau et sur
l'internaute et non pas sur les
entreprises pensent que si déjà pourrait
dire c'est bien de recevoir de la
publicité ciblée on se fait pas emmerder
avec toutes sortes de publicité qu'on
veut pas recevoir
oui mais la contrepartie de ça c'est que
ils savent où vous êtes
à chaque minute qu'est ce que vous
regardez qu'est ce que vous faites avec
qui etc
c'est là que ça devient lourd apple a
exactement 100 points de données on
disait dans le reportage le nom l'oeuvre
peut-être parfois vos opinions
politiques
à quelle manifestation vous êtes allé
évidemment c'est inquiétant mais il y
aura toujours de la publicité
il y en aura toujours pourquoi notamment
sur facebook parce que le modèle de
facebook c'est d'être toujours gratuit
et mark zuckerberg s'était fait poser la
question au congrès l'année dernière par
un sénateur un peu candide et il s'était
aussi fait piéger sur les données
personnelles on peut écouter
le rival no donc on le voit malaise
malaise de la part de mark zuckerberg
sur ses propres données personnelles
alors qu'il utilise celle des millions
d'utilisateurs de facebook donc oui ce
que dit ces entreprises c'est qu'il y
aura toujours de la publicité est ce que
vous voulez qu'elles soient pertinentes
ou est ce que vous voulez qu'elle ne
soit pas pertinente qu'elle ne vous
intéresse pas la question que l'usager
lui se pose c'est jusqu'où ira cette
surveillance jusqu'où ira cette collecte
de données personnelles et qu'il y aura
accès aux souvient patrice cambridge
analytique à 87 millions d'utilisateurs
dont les données avaient été perdues
disséminés volet savait à l'avancé la
présidentielle américaine s'est pas de
l'altruisme facebook là c'est une charge
puis ainsi de la publicité effectivement
merci matthew fort intéressant merci
compris